همم المباركه للمنتخب السعودي بفوزه يعني
العريق والمستحق على
الارجنتين واتمنى ان تستمر الانتصارات
السعوديه لقد ابدى يعني المنتخب السعودي
يعني رجوله وفروسيه
وشجاعه في هذه المباراه همم التي يعني
شهاده كما تفضلتم يعني همم جن سكان الارض
يعني سواء كانوا عرب او عرب لان همم
المونديال يعني حاله استثنائيه في كره
القدم
لانها يعني مونديال الشعوب
وبالتالي كره القدم اصبحت هي الكره هي
اللعبه الشعبيه همم الاكثر عراقه والاكثر
يعني الاهتمام نظرا وربما هذا يعني همم
اجابه عن سؤالك عن سر هذه همم الشعبيه ان
طبيعه هذه اللعبه يعني غير مكلفه همم
طبيعه تقوم على العمل الجماعي اكثر من شخص
يعني يؤدي
مهمات في هذه اللعبه لا تحتاج هذه اللعبه
الى همم يعني همم الى دعم لوجستي انت
تحتاج الى همم كنا نقول عنها طابه يعني
نصنعها احيانا من يعني من ملابس من بعض
الاشياء حتى تتكون وتصبح يعني كره
تتقاذفها الاقدام وبالتالي همم انت تحتاج
الى يعني اشياء لوجيسيه بسيطه حتى تنشئ
ملعبا وتنشئ عارضه للمرمى تنشئ خطوطا
وهذه يعني في هناك متعه في في هذه اللعبه
متعه يعني لها علاقه
كما تفضل دكتور التحدي
بالمشاركه الجماعيه
رغبه بالفوز همم
كانت هذه البدايه في في في بدايه اللعبه
كما تقول همم يعني همم
الاجندات التاريخيه او الادبيات التاريخيه
كانت حكرا على الطبقه الاستقراطيه في
انجلترا لكنها سرعان ما تحولت الى لعبه
شعبيه كان يمارسها العمال فهي كانت تسمى
لعبه همم العمال وبالتالي انتشرت في ال-
اا يعني الحواري في المناطق الفقيره همم
ولم تكن تحتاج الى اي كلفه